Let's uh do a quick review of lecture
five kind of remind ourselves where we
left off uh so we started talking about
Imus or uh inertial sensors
and uh we kind of broke it down into two
main types of sensors accelerometers and
gyroscopes so so far we've only talked
about accelerometers uh specifically
mechanical accelerometers and we said
that the from a mechanical architecture
point of view these are uh just damped
spring Mass systems in an enclosure or a
damped harmonic oscillator in an
enclosure so here's a very simple
diagram showing it so you have your
enclosure which in the case of a mems
device is just basically a the chip
enclosure and then there is a spring
with constant K there's a proof Mass
with mass m and then there's some
damping mechanism with damping Factor B
and as an external acceleration is
applied to the enclosure it basically
that force uh is is coupled to the proof
Mass through this spring and then we
showed that by solving Newton's
equations we showed that the
displacement of the proof Mass inside
the enclosure is directly proportional
to the applied acceleration in the case
that the acceleration waveform applied
has its or its frequency content is
within the bandwidth of the device right
because this is spring Mass system you
can think of it as kind of like a low
pass filter so if you apply very high
frequency inputs you would not get a
response from this every device has some
bandwidth specifically so the transfer
function that we derived for the system
h of Omega is given by this function so
h of Omega is basically the Fourier
transform of your response which is this
x divided by the Fourier transform of
the input waveform applied or a okay and
that's given by this expression
-1 over
Omega 0 squared minus Omega squared plus
J B Omega over M where Omega 0 remember
is basically the resonance frequency of
the system that also determines the
bandwidth of the system and it's related
to the mass and the spring constant so
Omega 0 is
um
it's the square root of K Over M I think
um so that's Omega 0. and in the case
again where if if uh if the frequency
content of your input the omegas are
less than Omega zero you can approximate
this very well by just a constant which
is -1 over Omega 0 which we call the
sensitivity of the device okay so that
basically is a scale factor that you can
just apply to a and you get the
displacement X okay uh so and and that's
written here
uh okay so
um one thing to note is that this device
can only measure contact or specific
forces and we made an example that for
instance if you just let it free fall in
some gravitational field it would not be
able to measure because there is no uh
there's no contact to to uh to anything
basically in that situation but but in
in cases where you have some contact for
Supply it just works well and uh so then
uh from there basically to to complete
the design of the sensor we said that we
need a mechanism to measure this
displacement accurately and the way it's
typically implemented is using
capacitive sensing so you basically tie
this proof Mass to a moving plate of a
capacitor and then put that in the
middle of a fixed capacitor and as the
plate moves you basically pick up a
voltage that is proportional to X
linearly and then basically your your
sensor design is complete you just need
to measure that voltage
pass that through an ADC to bring it to
the digital domain and then by some very
simple math basically you need to first
map the voltage to displacement which is
your first linear transform Mission and
then displacement to acceleration which
is just the scaling right that's just
times your sensitivity and then you
basically are done right so there's a
little bit of simple math that the
device need needs to do to basically
give you uh acceleration directly any
questions
okay so let's continue
um so we have been mentioning uh
basically uh mems a bunch of times and I
do want to
talk a little bit about uh how how these
devices are fabricated using uh mems uh
mems processes uh before uh we talk
about mems one thing to note is that
remember the the displacement of the
proof mask can be very small right so
we're talking about nanometers possibly
even like sub nanometer displacements um
so the electronics specifically this
capacitive sensor needs to be sensitive
enough to pick up very small signals and
for that you want to basically maximize
your signal to noise Ratio or maximize
how much signal you pick up given a
displacement of the proof Mass so uh the
signal is again picked up capacitive so
you want to maximize the capacitance
right the more capacitance you have in
your capacitive sensor that means you
get better SNR you just couple more
signal from the movement of the proof
Mass to uh your sensing mechanism so
because of that a common technique is
that instead of just two plates for the
capacitor you basically
build as as many plates or fingers as
possible it's still the same concept
right so you have a bunch of uh plates
or fingers that are tied to your proof
mass and move with it and then
externally you have your fixed uh
capacitor fingers replaced but now you
have many of them so it's like kind of
like a comb design and then as your
proof Mass moves you just pick up uh the
signal that is uh linearly proportional
to the displacement but now you have
much more capacitance right so you have
just just increased the surface area
between the electrodes by times n where
n is basically the number of fingers
which means you have more capacity than
so you pick up a stronger signal and and
that really really helps so you
basically can increase your SNR by
orders of magnitude with this with this
trick and then the rest is uh basically
what we have talked about uh so this is
a 1D case so in in the in Silicon you
basically have some anchor points and
then you generate Springs here there I'm
just showing them as lines but these are
really kind of like uh spring patterns
and then uh you have your proof mass in
this case moving in in X Direction and
then uh your your capacitive electrodes
pick up pick up the signal uh here's a
one uh simple uh video I would like to
show to which does a better job than my
my drawing here so before I play it
um
so what you see here it's a simulation
okay finite element simulation and this
is a sensor that was designed for say a
an airbag sensor that needs to pick up
uh impact and activate the the airbag so
on the left you would see this car is
going to drive and it's gonna hit that
trash can I think and on the top uh
sorry on the left and then on the top
right uh you see kind of like the mems
structure so uh the inertial mass or the
proof mass is uh uh is at the center and
then you have your capacitive plates and
the Springs are at the two ends
basically so this thing is going to just
move in in One Direction and see what
happens as the car basically comes over
and uh
hits it and you see how it moves and
that's the basically the signal that the
capacitor uh picks up Play One More Time
and there you go this is like a slow
motion view but you see how the proof
Mass moves back and forth and then the
capacitance changes accordingly and you
pick up the signal so
um so that's basically the idea and uh
if you look at basically uh how this is
uh
fabricated using the mems process so
what the mems process is again men's is
a huge field I mean you can you can do
your entire PhD on mems but in in one
minute basically uh what it enables is
that it kind of combines micro Machining
techniques with silicon fabrication
techniques and what's really nice about
that is that on one silicon chip you can
fabricate both your mechanical structure
which is the mass the Springs the
dampening mechanism the the capacitor uh
plates or fingers as well as all your
electronics so it's all basically
monolithically fabricated on one die and
you get this one chip that has
everything integrated in it
um
the way it works at a high level it's
kind of like a sequential process you
start with a silicon wafer then you
deposit some material on it then you
apply a mask which kind of like
selectively masks some areas of of the
of your material then you etch away
whatever material that was not masked
then you remove your mask deposit
another layer mask again
etch so it's like sequential material
deposition masking etching material
deposition masking etching of course I'm
super over simplifying it but that's the
high level idea and by designing the the
right mask patterns and controlling the
deposition process and the the material
thicknesses you can build very intricate
structures in Maps Okay and one thing we
haven't quite talked about is uh in
terms of fabrication is the dampening
mechanism and the damping mechanism is
actually interesting so it's achieved by
basically putting your spring Mass
system in a chamber inside the the chip
and close it and basically have some
inert gas in there and just the
viscosity of the gas
generates uh the damping that you want
so by controlling basically the pressure
and what specific inert gas they put in
the chamber
they achieve the dampening that is
required for the device of course what's
very important here is it needs to be
airtight so other gas or liquid
molecules cannot get in or out of the
chamber because if anything gets in or
out the viscosity is is going to change
which then changes the dampening factor
and a change of dampling factor of
course we know can very significantly
change the the behavior of your device
so you can suddenly be become
overdamped or under damped or you know
everything can can can change if if that
basically gas composition or density
changes
okay so uh let's look at some pictures
uh to better see what these men's
devices look like this is an actual uh
electron microscope image of uh at one
of the very first commercial mems
accelerators that was built by Bosch
this is probably
um I should check but I want to say it's
probably from le2000s maybe uh like
20-ish years ago so that's where the
mems were becoming kind of like
commercialized and it's exactly what you
expect right so you have your two
springs on the side so these this and
that these are those are the springs and
they're anchored to the to the Silicon
on the two ends and then your proof mass
is basically this long narrow structure
here and then most of the basically area
of of the device is is taken up by the
capacitive sensor so you see these are
like you have your fixed fingers and in
between those there's the moving fingers
that are tied to the proof mask and it
kind of makes sense again you you want
the device to pick up very very small
signals so you need to generate a lot of
capacitance so that it can pick up very
small signals and that's why uh most of
the basically footprint of the device is
is used up by the by the capacitors
um
okay let's look at some more uh uh
modern ones
but before that so far we have just
talked about uh one-dimensional
accelerometers but it turns out that uh
it the exact same principle can be done
in two and and three axes okay so here's
a 2d case exact same principle you have
a proof Mass right and then you have
Springs at the corners okay and now
instead of restricting the motion just
to one axis uh By Design of the Springs
you let the mass move into axes X and Y
right and then you add basically two
sets of capacitive sensors one is gonna
so the ones at the top and bottom the
capacitance is going to change when the
mass moves horizontally and the
capacitive sensors that are on the left
and the right of the proof Mass those
guys it's the capacitance is going to
change when when the proof Mass moves
vertically right so with that again all
the principle of operation the physics
it's all the same but now you can sense
acceleration in two dimensions and with
that you can also Imagine like how you
can do it in in 3D also again it's the
same principle you just let the the mass
move in uh three dimensions and add
another you know capacitive sensor at
the top and bottom of it basically and
and that's it that's how you build a 2d
or a 3D of course I mean we are over
simplifying it when it comes if you if
you talk to a men's expert they can I'm
sure talking for hours about like all
the challenges associated with you know
uh
um the the the to to get the process to
exactly you know build you something
that does this but at the at the
principle lower physics level I mean
it's the same idea uh how how you do it
in in 2D or 3D so here's a picture of a
two axis uh man's accelerometer this one
is from Analog Devices it's it's a more
recent device I think this was being
used up till a few years ago maybe you
might still be able to get it if you
search for that part number maybe but
here you see how small it is right I
mean these devices are a few millimeters
by a few millimeters I mean compared to
a quarter you see how small it is and
then if you remove the cap of the device
and put it under a microscope this is
what you see right this is just an
ordinary image like even a lab
microscope you can if you ever get one
of these devices I encourage you to do
it you can just cut the top and put it
under a microscope and you see this here
and the interesting thing like the
octagonal thing that is pretty complex
looking at the center that's the actual
mechanical part so there's the proof
Mask The Springs the the capacitive
sensors and all that which you see
zoomed in and then everything around it
those are the electronics those are your
uh the the ADC the the waveform
generator you know all the electronics
the amplifiers and the filters and all
that they're all on the same basically
die
monolithically fabricated as as we said
and then if you zoom in on the actual
memsa structure so that then this one
you need like an electron microscope to
look at these things are fascinating I
mean you zoom in and they look like I
don't know structures built by aliens or
something like that but now we
understand what it is the the big Square
looking thing in the center that's the
proof mass and as we said in this case
it can move in two axes right so here
the two axes are kind of diagonal X and
Y and then you have your Springs at the
corners and you see you have two Springs
on on at Each corner because you wanted
to move into axes right and then you
have your uh capacitive fingers to pick
up uh the the signal capacitively and if
you even further zoom in that's that's
the the structure it's really really
fascinating training uh to to to look at
especially once you consider the scale
of things so just to give you a sense of
scale the full width of this suspension
spring here is probably around a few
tens of microns maybe 100 Micron or so
um okay so between the fingers we're
talking like single digit microns
probably spacing or something like that
now note that these types of sensors
like accelerometers
they did exist before mems technology
was developed but they were these huge
like mechanical things with like weights
and springs and they were not reliable
the bandwidths were low and you know not
very useful and then as the mems
technology was developed it's it's
really fascinating to me like how how
far along we have come with with these
fabrication techniques and again this is
not state-of-the-art this devices
probably
um I don't know if you years old maybe
five or ten years old okay one more
example yes
two masses and two springs for each
Direction
uh which part so the question is it
looks like there's two masses and two
springs for each Direction two Springs
you are correct
um so actually there's four springs for
each Direction uh so if you look at here
uh let's call this diagonal axis our X
and then you have like one two three
four so you have one spring at every
corner and then same for y right
um but it's all but the mass is just one
so it's it's it's basically the thing at
the center plus it has like these uh
little you know smaller Square looking
thingies attached to it on the side so
it's kind of like a I don't know what
you call it but it's like a cross almost
but it's all one piece it's not two
separate masses you can have two
separate masses and actually in the next
uh example I'll show you one where one
of the axes is completely decoupled okay
um
like
so there's four finger sets in total my
two for each leg so is that for like
redundancy or yeah so the question is
like uh the capacitive sensors do we
have two for each axis right so again in
if you call this our x-axis there's
these guys under these guys and
um it's not for redundancy it's again to
maximize the signal you pick up you want
as much capacitance as you want so
you're leveraging the both sides of the
device and you know uh getting more
capacitance out of it right more
capacitance more signal yes is this like
using active control uh question is is
this using active control and the one
shown here that's a great question I
don't think so just looking at the
structure here I don't quite see uh
actuator here except this thing here
um which I am not sure it's it's not
enough for active actuation I would say
usually you want like almost like a full
Com Drive for uh for active feedback so
I don't think this one is actively
controlled
um but we can go pull up the the data
sheet for this device I'm sure it's
available online and double check but
just looking at it it doesn't look like
to me it's actively controlled okay next
one is from uh iPhone uh not the most
recent one this is a iPhone 4 when was
it 20 years ago almost
no not 2015 14 years ago something like
that anyway so this is from iPhone 4.
and if you take an iPhone 4 and open it
up and take out the main logic board uh
just next to the CPU the A4 chip there's
two very small chips a few millimeters
by a few millimeters and this one here
is the three axis accelerometer in the
in the iPhone 4. and if you Decap the
chip and put it under a microscope again
you see this very very interesting memsa
structure and this one
um
back to uh question is uh one of the
axes is completely decoupled from the
other two so here you have one proof
mass that moves in X and Y directions
right and they have done some very
interesting structure with the
capacitive sensor so these guys here are
the capacitive fingers for x and then
you see horizontal ones for y and the
proof Mass here is kind of like a cross
structure with a frame around it so the
proof mass is basically this plus across
in the middle and then you have four
Springs on this side so that guy moves
in uh left right up down and then there
is an entirely separate piece of the
memsa structure which is for z-axis
acceleration sensing and this one here
moves basically in and out of the plane
right so in this view we do not see the
capacitive sensors because it goes
underneath teeth and on top of it so
it's like a multi-layer design basically
and again if you zoom in on a piece of
this you see this uh very very intricate
structure of the here you see like the
capacitor plates this is part of the
proof mass and this is the spring here
and there's some very interestingly all
connected to each other if we zoom in a
little more and I just noticed I think
this arrow is misplaced so it should
come out of this little green box here
I'll fix that
um
just like that okay so if you further
zoom in into the X Y part of the device
this zoomed in picture probably shows
better like what's what's uh going on
right so so you have your Springs you
have your capacitive fingers and then
you have your proof mask which again is
like all around plus kind of like a
cross-like structure
um at the at the center okay
any questions
okay so since we uh are looking at at an
iPhone I want to tell you an interesting
story so we talked about mems and we
said that uh the damping mechanism is uh
is is done by having an inert gas in a
chamber so basically you can think of
like this entire memsa structure in the
chip being enclosed and then there's
some inner gas inside that chamber and
then the viscosity of the gas determines
the dampening Factor so
um this is this is like for most people
it's even like design Engineers this is
detail right nobody cares like whatever
is in it it's a device it works we just
use it right
yes until one morning you wake up
say you are an apple
iPhone engineer to this news headline
iPhones are allergic to helium and this
was a fascinating story it's on iFixit I
encourage you to read it but basically
at a high level what happened is that in
some Hospital in Chicago in 2018
suddenly everybody's iPhones stopped
working they completely were doing crazy
things like shutting down turning back
on and things and they started reaching
out to Apple like what what is going on
and uh it took them a while to figure
out actually there were these what
theories of maybe your MRI machines are
generating weird electromagnetic
interference or this or that but it
turned out that there was helium leak in
one of the hospital floors and the men's
devices in the phones
they were not the the ceiling of the
mems chamber and it was only tested
under normal atmospheric conditions
which is mostly composed of oxygen and
nitrogen which are big molecules so
those molecules could not like get into
the chamber and it was fine but helium
mark cues are much smaller and they
could penetrate into the mems device
change the viscosity of it and guess
what everything goes crazy right your
damping factors changes your
accelerometer starts doing weird things
also the oscillators and many new
electronics or men's devices so also
helium was getting into the the
oscillators and completely messing up
with the clock of the device and things
were stopping working so even at like
for Apple it it took a while to really
figure out and this article has a full
analysis it even shows you like the the
the insides of the the men's gyroscopes
and devices so it's a pretty fun article
to read about but for me the lesson is
well this was kind of an isolated case
and yes it was bad but it was figured
out in in the
next Generations of the devices they
change the ceiling material to make sure
it's like airtight for smaller molecules
things like that but what if this has
happened in a
um a robot that was sent to a planet and
many planets could have atmospheres rich
in helium and then suddenly uh you there
is like many many years of research and
development and billions of dollars is
spent on some I don't know Mars Rover or
something Mars doesn't have much helium
but something that goes
out into space and then suddenly as soon
as the thing lands and the robot exits
the landing module it just goes crazy
and shuts down so that's why I think
it's really really important to
understand at this level of detail how
sensing works even like down to the
fabrication processes because
when things don't work it's that's
that's actually when uh you you
understand the importance of these
things okay any questions
all right so
last topic related to accelerometers is
about the noise and resolution of these
devices and for noise
um
I don't want to go into all the details
that is in the notes so basically from
the uh what is called the fluctuation
dissipation theorem you can build a
model of the thermal noise in these
devices and all uh in the interest of
time I'll skip the details uh you can
you can read about it but there's a full
derivation there but at the end of it
basically from this theorem uh what you
can do is you can calculate the variance
of the thermal noise in these devices
okay so this expression here that's the
variance so a a sub n is uh is is the
noise or or the the the noise portion of
the acceleration that the device
measures and we're taking like the
variance of it and as you see it's given
by this expression here so it has the
boltzmann constant in it that's case of
B it's proportional to absolute
temperature so at higher temperatures
the devices get noisier it is also
proportional so this Delta F here is the
bandwidth of the signal you're trying to
measure so higher bandwidth picks up
more uh more noise and then you have
this Omega 0 over M here so Omega 0
again is the resonance frequency of your
device and then you have one over M uh
what's important here from from this
expression is actually this m in the
denominator because remember last time
we said that uh generally the the value
of the proof mass m it does not affect
the sensitivity of the device because
devices the sensitivity is 1 over Omega
squared and Omega is kind of dictated by
the application but we see that for
noise it actually makes a difference so
large mass does not increase sensitivity
but it does decrease noise that's very
important so if you want to design a
device for very very low noise
applications you want to design it with
a larger value of the proof Mass okay
and then from there you can basically
derive a full kind of like the noisy
Spectrum again I'll I'll skip over the
details but here is uh some data we can
look at so this is
um basically the the plot we are seeing
here this is from a real data sheet of
an accelerometer and it it shows
basically the the noise
power Spectrum so as a function of
frequency how much noise you expect from
the device as you see close to DC
there's always more noise so that's kind
of your 1 over F that we have talked
about a few times so and generally
that's why I mean always lower frequency
parts of the spectrum are noisier but
above that you basically get to a noise
floor and it's usually coded in units of
uh micro G per root Hertz and uh what's
important is for your application you
can basically you want if you're
choosing what accelerometer you want to
use you can look at the data sheet go to
the noise part where this information is
given and then you also probably have
some idea of the signals you would be
dealing with for your application and if
you roughly know what the bandwidth of
your signal is then you can basically
integrate this noise function over the
bandwidth of your signal and find the
actual noise variants that you expect
from the device and then you can decide
okay is this too much noise for me does
this work like is my signal going to be
above noise floor or not and so on and
so forth if this curve is not given it's
usually given from measurements but if
it's not
basically that a formula that I showed
you you can plug in numbers into that
that's a simplified model based on
fluctuation dissipation theorem and that
can predict the noise floor of the
device for you and here we have done
that and as you see see the actual noise
floor which is this like red and blue
the red and blue they tested basically
two different devices and they're
showing that they have basically the
same noise so you can just look at one
of them and then the screen dotted uh
um green dotted line is basically the
average of it so that's 75 micro G per
root Hertz that's what from measurements
uh they're telling us and if you use our
simple model for the noise floor you get
a number that is pretty close to that
you get 60 instead of 75 but order of
magnitude wise you're you're going to be
very close so again if this is not
available you can use your simplified
model to estimate noise you need some
information you need proof mass and
Omega 0 and a few other things but you
can use the formula yes
variance
like intuitively intuitively what is the
what is the noise variance so what it is
is basically
um
let's say you have some as a function of
time
you have some
a external of some acceleration waveform
applied to your device okay it can be
anything but let's say it's I don't know
it like goes up and does something like
that okay so let's say this is the
actual thing applied and then what your
device actually measures is not the
perfect waveform but there's always a
little bit of
fluctuation around it so this blue one
might be I'm exaggerating the noise but
just to get the idea there's like a
little bit of wiggliness on top of the
actual physical waveform apply and the
noise variance is basically kind of like
if you just take the uh the the small
deviations from the ground truth
acceleration applied that's kind of like
a random variable for you and then if
you find the variance of that guy that
Sigma squared noise that's the variance
of those small fluctuations
uh going back to where the formula was
okay so we were here
noise variance varies
yes so it says that the noise noise
variance is has it it it exactly it like
the more bandwidth the the more noise
but this is your kind of like your
measurement bandwidth so if your signal
um
in in the in the the spectrum of the
signal has more frequency content in it
I think actually it's easier to answer
your question on this plot so you see
like every every frequency has some
noise on it right now if you have if I
draw my signal on top of this and let's
use yellow and let's say like the the
Fourier transform of my waveform applied
I'm just going to make up something but
it looks like this
okay that means only the noise
from one Hertz to 10 Hertz is in band
with my signal everything else in
principle I can filter out right like in
the DSP because I know I'm dealing with
a signal that has only frequency content
from one to ten everything out of band I
can apply like a digital filter or
something like that and kind of get rid
of it and that's why only and then this
would be the Delta f
whatever is inbound I cannot do anything
with it that noise is gonna make it into
my final measurement there is no
technique to really get out of inbound
noise so that's why that's kind of like
your best case scenario that if you
really fit the the the the your filter
bandwidth to your signal and get rid of
out of out of band noise you're still
going to be left with some noise
variance that is proportional to the
signal bandwidth okay
other questions
okay let's uh continue
okay so in addition to noise there's
also some systematic errors in the in
the measurements that you get out of
accelerometer and uh specifically
there's three effects uh one is called
bias and bias is basically just constant
offset in your readouts
um
and it can come from manufacturing
non-idealities so maybe for instance
your your proof mass at rest is not
perfectly centered or you where you
assume was like x equals zero is not
where it actually lies uh could be like
some non-idealities in the capacitive
sensors or other things so you can have
bias then there's a scale errors so
scalars are basically inaccuracies in
the calculated sensitivity so remember
sensitivity is a function of your proof
mass m and also the spring Mass K right
so you're gonna assume some nominal
values for those but if the actual
values because of again manufacturing
tolerances are not equal to the assumed
values those are going to show up as a
scaling error so the assumed sensitivity
is not the actual sensitivity and
finally you would have a crosstalk
effect and crosstalk this is only a
problem if you are sensing in more than
one axis and that's the fact that you
can have a little little bit of coupling
of the signal or your measurement
between different axes so if for
instance
your
as your proof Mass moves in the x-axis
again because of non-idealities in the
in the fabrication process your
capacitive sensors for the y-axis pick
up a little bit of signal that's false
signal that's just cross dot signal that
was coupled from acceleration in one
axis into your sensor in the other axis
and there's always a little bit of
crosstalk but what's important is
these effects they can to a large extent
be mitigated through calibration right
you can build up a mathematical model
for it and then you can measure these
basically by some careful measurements
and then you can cancel them out in in
DSP so specifically you're you're based
on to model these three effects your
signal model looks something like this
so so what this is is that a tilde here
which is a vector you're talking about
the most General case which is a three
axis accelerometer so yeah this is what
the readout that you actually get out of
the device at the XYZ and then it is
equal to this three by three Matrix we
call M and we'll clarify what it is
times the actual physical acceleration
that's a
plus noise so this a sub n is the noise
and it has three components in x y and z
and then you also add a beta which is
just a constant bias added to it okay so
your atility is M times a plus noise
plus beta and what is m so the diagonal
entries of your Matrix M which we call
Alphas those are your scale factors that
we talked about okay so ideally if there
is no scaling error these Alphas should
be one right that means your a to the x
is is just one times ax right and then
the non-diagonal terms which we call
kappos those are your crosstalk terms
right so again in the ideal case you
want your M Matrix to be equal to
Identity right that means there's no
scalars and there's no cross stock also
in the ideal case you want beta to be
zero because that means there is no
offset okay
you never like out of fabrication you
never get the ideal thing but because
you have the signal model you can
measure these right you can measure the
bias you can measure the the
crosstalks and the scale errors and in
DSP you can correct for it and that
process is called calibration right
every device you buy these days they are
calibrated
so that's why uh you you get what you
get out of the device it is still not
perfect okay but what you get is the
alpha eyes are very close to one and
then the capitals are very close to zero
and also the beta is typically very
small the data sheet of the device uh
usually tells you what to expect expect
so they tell you what the bias is and
they tell you what level of crosstalk to
expect from the device
and the reason there is still after
calibration there's some residual uh
non-idealities in your signal the reason
is typically the calibration uh is is uh
it's the same calibration applied to all
devices that are manufactured right so
they build up a model of their
manufacturing tolerances and
non-idealities and then based on that
model they basically fit this signal
model and find what the alphas and the
kappas and the betas are and then they
invert that in their DSP and make that
like a calibration model now what
happens is that that's that is great it
gets uh it takes care of a lot of these
effects but there's still device to
device variations right so you build a
million of these devices there is the
process variations across those are not
going to be exact same and that's why if
you apply the same calibration to all of
them it's not going to be perfect
sometimes you get a device that is a
little bit better or a little bit worse
so if your application uh requires much
much better
calibration you need to do a per device
calibration so you can buy
one or a bunch of these devices build up
your own calibration rig that applies
say controlled acceleration in different
axes and measure the readout of the
device and then fit this to it right do
your own additional uh fit to this
signal model and then invert that and by
invert I mean you just like take your
atld subtract beta from it and then
multiply it by m inverse basically and
then you just get basically your signal
plus noise is always going to be there
there's not much you can do about noise
but all these other systematic errors
you can do much better and most
applications do not require extra
calibration usually you just find a
device which from the data sheet you
know by Design is guaranteed to have the
right
amount of or a tolerable amount of like
gain variations and crosstalk and things
like that but if you are working on a
super super sensitive application that
requires almost perfect sensors then you
can do additional calibration any
questions
okay so with this we are basically done
with accelerometers and we're gonna move
forward to talk about gyroscopes okay
now for gyroscopes um
the physics is a little more complicated
than accelerometers accelerometers was
just simple you know linear motion
spring Mass system gyroscope is a little
more complicated and because of that I
want to start from scratch and first
build a mathematical framework that lets
us analyze the physics of rotational
motion right so remember gyroscope needs
to measure angular velocity so there's
going to be rotations and we first build
a mathematical framework to study
rotational motion okay so let's start
with this idea of rotating reference
frame okay so again as always Whenever
there is physical quantities that we
want to describe or measure we need to
clarify what reference frame or what
coordinate system these are measured in
okay so here let's assume two different
coordinate systems one is a fixed frame
it's it's drawn in black and it's called
s0 so this never changes right this is
your fixed reference frame x y z okay
and then assume there is a rotating
reference frame okay and that's drawn in
blue and we call it S Sub R so that's
the rotating s and it's going to with
some angular velocity it's going to keep
rotating right to describe the rotation
uh it's typically done by a vector which
is called Omega because for rotation you
need to specify two things the axis of
rotation and the angular velocity right
so we Define this Vector drawn in Orange
Omega the direction of it is or the unit
Vector along Omega is the axis of
rotation
and the norm of Omega is the angular
velocity okay so then with one vector
you describe the full full rotation the
axis of rotation and the the angular
velocity and it's always
um by the right right hand rule so if
you if you point your thumb along Omega
then your fingers are going to basically
curl in the direction of rotation right
so that's that
and for now let's study just one point
there's a point p okay and uh that that
that we're gonna look at and for now
let's assume the point p
is static in the rotating reference
frame okay
Let's uh uh I want to make sure this
makes sense so this point p is kind of
like tied to the rotating frame
in that frame it fixed it it is fixed
which means in the fixed frame p is
going to be rotating with angular
velocity Omega okay
um so specifically if we look uh along
the axis of rotation Omega so we are
kind of like in in this right side
picture we're looking along Omega
Omega is actually coming out of the
plane in this picture and then the way
the the the P is moved as observed in
the fixed frame it's going to move in a
circle right counterclockwise and uh
it's movement from one point in time to
the to the next one so if You observe P
at time T and then go to time t plus DT
it's going to move on this circle by an
amount which is basically the the radius
of this circle times that little angle
of rotation the angle of rotation is
just going to be the angular velocity
which is normal of Omega times DT that's
assuming Omega is fixed that's just the
angular motion and then the actual
movement on this circle is going to be
Omega DT times the radius of the circle
which is uh if if you call that R that's
going to be just Norm R so this little
arrow which is the movement of Point T
is Norm R Norm Omega DT in the direction
Phi hat where Phi hat is the tangent to
The Circle at at P one more thing to
note here on the on the left side we
have kind of projected our Point P onto
two directions so you can write your p
as
U plus r where U is the projection onto
the Omega Direction so that's U
and R is the basically the perpendicular
component to to Omega and as the point P
rotates
in the fixed frame U is not going to
change right it's only R that's kind of
like changing U is always going to be
the same
by by construction it's uh it's that way
and then we have this little angle Theta
which is the angle between p and the
Omega which is the axis of rotation
does the geometry make sense so far
okay so two frames one fix one rotating
and then we have a point P that is fixed
in the rotating frame which means it's
rotating in the fixed frame it's a
little confusing but uh that's that's
the that's a problem setup okay now
let's look at the motion of uh p and
specifically we want to calculate the
derivative the time derivative of p in
the fixed reference frame s0 okay so we
want to find DP DT in s0 okay we just
said that you can write p as U plus r
so substitute that so you get D DT of U
plus r which is d u d t plus Dr DT right
now remember that we said U is fixed in
actually in both frames it's fixed since
it's fixed in s r it's fixed in s0 U
never changes it's r that
causes the rotation right so the first
term is zero dudt uh all we need to
calculate is Dr DT right and to find the
rdt we just uh in in the in the previous
uh slide if I go back here we calculated
what Dr is like this this little arrow
here that Vector that's the r that's how
much R changes in a small time increment
right so we can just use that so Dr is r
at t plus DT minus r of T which we just
showed is equal to Norm of R which is
the radius of that Circle of rotation
times
Omega DT is this small angle of rotation
right and it's in the direction of Phi
hat okay also remember that the way we
constructed our U and R vectors I'm just
going to draw it again here so this was
U and then there was this Vector R and
this was P this this was the point P
right and then we had this angle Theta
here right
so by the geometry of this this right
triangle here we see that Norm r
is equal to Norm p
times sine Theta right
so let's substitute that into here so we
get Norm P Norm Omega sine Theta DT in
the direction Phi hat that is Dr so
divide both sides by DT then our Dr DT
becomes Norm P Norm Omega sine Theta in
the direction Phi hat so that is the
time derivative of P observed in the
fixed reference frame okay now this
expression should be familiar for you
because that is the definition of a
vector cross product okay this is how a
vector cross product is is defined
between p and Omega so then the
derivative of PDP DT in the fixed frame
s0 is basically equal to the cross
product of your rotation Vector Omega
and your point P
Omega cross p
okay
any questions so far
now why are we doing this again and
remember we want to study
inertial forces that are related to
rotation and in order to find forces we
know we need to find accelerations which
are the derivatives of position right so
that's where we are starting first we
have found the first derivative of a
position of the position of a point that
is moving in a fixed frame and very soon
you're going to look at the second
derivative but before that we need to
our mathematical framework is still not
General enough why isn't it General
enough because of the assumption that we
made one slide back here we said that
point p is static in Sr right so we
assume that P in the it's not rotating
relative or moving relative to the
rotating frame we need to generalize
that right so let's remove that
assumption now let's look at a point P
that is moving in the rotating reference
frame so now the point is going to be
moving basically in both frames it's
going to be moving in the rotating frame
it's going to be moving in the fixed
frame right it's the most General
description of a point that that you
have there's no
restricting assumptions on the Dynamics
of the point so we can describe the
position of Point T in the rotating
reference frame Sr as basically it's
it's three components right it's going
to be some p x r times x hat r p y r y
hat r p z r z hat R where this x hat r y
hat r z hat R are the three basis
vectors of our rotating frame right so
these three unit vectors describe
basically the x y z coordinates of the
rotating frame okay so X hat r y hat r z
hat are in the rotating frame they're
fixed right because they're the basis
vectors but as observed in the fixed
frame the x-hat Y hat Z hat of Sr are
going to be rotating okay
so now again let's try to find the time
derivative of our Point p in the fixed
frame as zero here the math is going to
get a little bit hairy but all we're
doing before we do it is is just going
to be applying the the
something like the chain rule of
derivatives and just some refactoring
okay first step is okay so we want to
find DP DT in in s0 so we are going to
start taking the derivative of this guy
okay so it's the sum of three terms but
each term as you take the derivative uh
using the chain rule gives you basically
two terms right so this first term here
as you take the derivative you get two
terms you get DPX rdt times x hat R plus
Pax R times DX hat rdt right because
both of as seen in the s0 both of these
guys are going to be time varying so you
need to apply the chain rule of of
derivatives so we do that
and then we
do some refactoring so from first line
to Second Line we have just reordered
things there's no real math done here so
we get these three terms
in the first parentheses and then which
is DPX DT dpydt dpz DT times x hat r y
hat or Z hat or what is this this is
just the derivative of Point p in the
rotating reference frame right so this
this first one uh we can just more
concisely write it as DP DT in the
rotating frame right
that's the first one and then for the
second one
the second term we J we use the uh
um basically what we just derived for
the time derivatives of fixed vectors
right remember X hat r y hat R and Z hat
are are fixed in the rotating frame
because those are the basis vectors so
they're derivatives and the fixed frame
s0 are just going to be Omega cross
X at R this one is going to be Omega
cross this is what we just derived in
the previous slide right and Omega cross
the head R so plug that in we get these
three terms PX times Omega cross x p y
Omega plus y hat and pzr Omega cross Z
hat R uh we can factor out Omega
uh so this becomes Omega cross pxrx hat
r p y r y hat r p z r z hat R but what
is this this is just uh the point P
right this is what we had up here so you
just plug P for that and then it becomes
this simple expression uh so now our
mathematical framework is complete
because we can now find the time
derivative of any point with any type of
motion in two different frames of
references one is fixed the other one is
rotating and we know how the two are
mathematically related so your time
derivative as observed in the fixed
frame is equal to the time derivative as
observed in the rotating frame plus this
extra term which is Omega cross cross P
okay so this is really the main result
that we'll be working with so just to
summarize uh if you're given a fixed
reference frame s0 and a rotating
reference frame Sr with angular velocity
Omega and if you have some point P of T
which is moving
how what type of motion you want it's
moving relative to both frames then the
the time derivative of the point DP DT
and s0 is equal to its time derivative
and it's R plus this extra term which is
Omega cross P or more compactly if we
show the time derivatives by the dot
notation you get the P Dot and s0 is p
Dot and SR plus
Omega cross
p and so this this is velocity right if
p is the position of your point the time
derivative is velocity so we are
basically this expression
um
the physical quantities that it's
relating is the velocity observed for
the point in the fixed frame to the
velocity that is observed in the
rotating frame right and you would see
they are different you see different
velocities as you would expect right
because if you're moving
velocities look different to you any
questions
okay now we this is our complete
mathematical framework but we want to
find
forces for initial sensors right because
initially we can only measure forces not
velocities as we know so we basically
need to apply this mathematical
framework to see how forces in a fixed
frame are related to forces observed in
a rotating frame and once we do that
then we can see can we do something
about angular velocity or angular
acceleration or not okay so let's look
at forces so again we start with some
particle P sub t
a particle at a position P of T and
let's give it a mass because we want to
calculate forces on this guy so let's
say it has some mass m and let's see
what forces we observe in a fixed frame
and a rotating frame for this particle
in the fixed frame it's easy right it's
Newton's law so F observed in the fixed
frame s0 is just mass times acceleration
so it's m times
p double dot at s0 nothing new here okay
now let's look at what we observe if we
were tied to the rotating reference
frame okay
so uh again uh acceleration in the fixed
frame is just the second derivative of
the position in the fixed frame which is
D DT of velocity right so you
differentiate your velocity you get
acceleration
so
now we want to convert everything to the
rotating frame right here everything is
up to this point it's all in the fixed
frame let's first convert our P dot to
what it is in the rotating frame that's
what we just derived right so the the
time derivative in the fixed frame is
equal to P dot in the rotating frame
plus this extra term Omega cross B okay
now from here on again it's it's it's
pure calculus what we're going to do is
we're just going to take the derivative
of this guy and then the time derivative
of Omega cross p and multiple times we
are going to apply what we just uh
showed which I'm going to write it again
here if you have some Vector I'm going
to write it as X so it doesn't get mixed
up with our P but the time derivative of
x in a fixed frame is equal to the time
derivative in a rotating frame plus
Omega cross x x was bad here because now
okay that's a cross that's X
um so so that's what we just showed and
we're going to use it a bunch of times
on this expression okay let's start with
P dot what do we get if you want to
differentiate uh P Dot and Sr you get
p double dot so that's the derivative in
the rotating frame plus
Omega cross
your P dot NSR okay so these first two
terms are just our thing our
mathematical framework applied to P Dot
and S R and then you're going to do it
on Omega cross p uh here you first take
the derivative of Omega you get Omega
dot cross p
and then you get Omega across the
derivative of p and the derivative of t
p becomes an Sr frame becomes two terms
it becomes P dot SR plus again Omega
cross p
okay so we're multiple times applying
what we just showed how derivatives are
related between the two prints let's
reorder the things so what is p double
dot Sr that's your acceleration observed
in the rotating frame by definition
right then you get this term 2 Omega
cross p uh P dot s r uh Y2 because you
got it once here and ones here right so
that's the factor of two then your third
term is Omega dot cross p and finally
you get the last term which is Omega
cross Omega cross B that's like two
cross products
okay we are done basically so multiply
both sides by m to convert accelerations
to forces right your left hand side is
um
basically and and then we reorder things
so we just keep ASR on one side and take
all these three terms to the other side
so then the force observed in the
rotating frame which is mass times
acceleration in the rotating frame
becomes equal to mas0 that's this term
on top
this is a Newton Force this is the force
that you observe in the fixed frame and
then you get three extra terms
first one is minus two M Omega cross P
dot then you get minus M Omega cross
Omega cross p and then you get minus M
Omega dot cross B and
these show up as extra Force terms that
are only observed in the rotating
reference frame the first one is called
the Coriolis force and it's as you see
proportional to
Omega the angular velocity and P dot Sr
which is the the linear velocity of the
particle in in the rotating frame then
you get the second one is called the
centrifugal force which is um
kind of proportional to Omega squared
because you get Omega cross Omega cross
p and also the position of the device so
it's positioned and then after doing the
two cross products at the same amplitude
it should be proportional to angular
velocity squared and then the last one
is called the Euler Force which is
proportional to the position of the
device and the angular acceleration
there's Omega dot in here
so that's the expression here what's
really important to note is that
physically speaking there's only one
real force acting on your particle and
that's the force that you observe in a
fixed frame so only this first term the
Newton force is a real Force the these
three extra ones the Coriolis Force the
center centrifugal force and the Euler
Force these are pseudoforces also called
fictitious forces so these are not
actual physical forces acting on your
device uh on your particle but these are
just artifacts or observation artifacts
due to the fact that Sr is your frame of
reference is rotating and if your frame
of reference is rotating and you do not
know it's rotating because you're tied
to it then the Dynamics of the you see
different Dynamics and objects around
you and then you explain those Dynamics
by these fictitious forces that are F
lying on it okay so in summary
uh you get three pseudo forces observed
in a rotating reference frame so a force
in a rotating reference frame is the
physical Force fs0 plus the Coriolis
Force given by this expression minus two
Omega plus cross P Dot and S R plus the
centrifugal force minus Omega M Omega
cross Omega cross P
plus the Euler Force which is minus M
Omega dot cross cross P okay
so uh what is interesting from this is
what well first we We Now understand the
physics of rotating bodies okay
but also uh here's something actionable
because
um at least two of these forces are
proportional to the angular velocity so
if we can or one of them is actually
going to be proportional to angular
velocity squared but this first one
coriolis Force this is the magnitude of
it is going to be proportional to
angular velocity so if we can somehow
measure the Coriolis force in a rotating
reference frame from that we should be
able to calculate the angular velocity
that this is going to become the
principle of operation of a mechanical
accelerometer you need to measure the
Coriolis force and then somehow by doing
some math and DSP calculate the angular
velocity from it okay any questions
all right
so
um
here is uh
one more
kind of like a thought experiment I want
to walk you through to more solidify
like how how uh how the the Coriolis and
the centrifugal forces specifically uh
affect the Dynamics of an object as
observed in a rotating reference frame
okay so again assume some Mass with
position P of T and here what we're
moving what we're doing is that
um
this Mass let's first talk about a fixed
reference frame and in the fixed frame
the mass is moving radially outward with
some velocity constant velocity V okay
so if you're sitting in the fixed
reference frame you would see very
simple Dynamic for the mass it's just
going to move linearly at a constant
velocity that's it okay
now what would an observer in a rotating
reference frame C and if it's rotating
with a constant Omega okay what would
they observe and before before looking
at the math let's look at this uh
picture here and this picture uh we
should parse it uh carefully because the
way it's drawn is I am overlaying the
trajectory of the object as seen in the
two reference frames
on top of each other so first let's say
this point that the where the axis of
rotation passes through is our
center point also or the origin and this
dotted black line would be the
trajectory of our point in the fixed
reference frame so as I said it's just
going to move
uh on a cons on a line with a constant
velocity radially outward so it starts
at the origin and over time it just you
know just moves out
so the Dynamics in the fixed frame is
simple now what would an observer in a
rotating frame see
what the observer in the rotating frame
sees physically the object is still just
moving linearly right but because that
Observer is rotating they would think
that it's kind of like having this
curved motion right and it's only
because it's the Observer that's
rotating right so this dotted blue would
be the trajectory that somebody tied to
a rotating reference frame with a
constant angular velocity Omega would
see for the object
and the shape of this trajectory can be
explained by the fictitious forces right
so they would basically assign the two
fictitious forces which is the Coriolis
and the centrifugal force to the object
and that explains why it's going in a
curved direction right
um
there in this example there is no Euler
Force because we assumed Omega is
constant so Omega dot uh the time
derivative of Omega would be zero that
just makes the the Euler force zero and
we can exactly calculate what the
Coriolis and centrifugal forces are
going to be in this example coriolis 4
acceleration is the force over Mass
which we know is minus 2 Omega cross P
Dot and if we look at small time scales
right so let's assume we are just after
uh that the object starts moving uh we
we try to measure what the Coriolis
acceleration is so what that means is
that in this picture this is kind of
exaggerated a lot of time has passed in
this picture if you compare the two
trajectories and they have diverged
quite a bit but if you make your time
scale very small and you just you know
just look around the origin you see that
the the more oceans are are still pretty
much aligned as observed in the two uh
frames of references so with that uh
what what you can tell is that if T is
small uh your velocity that is observed
in the rotating frame is almost equal to
the actual true velocity V of the or at
least in magnitude it's it's equal to
that because
not enough time has passed yet for your
observations to deviate in the two in
the two reference frames so when you
want to calculate your Omega class cross
P dot
um what what it's equal to so we can use
our right hand rule so I'm going to do
it on the board here so um we're gonna
calculate Omega cross P Dot
again not a lot of time has passed so we
are kind of like still on this portion
right so what is Omega so Omega is
coming out of the plane my P dot is kind
of aligned still with this black dotted
line so my Omega cross P dot in
Direction it's going to be kind of uh
pointing up but in magnitude what P dot
is is just the the magnitude of v-rad
magnitude of Omega is the angular
velocity factor of two just carries over
and the two vectors are orthogonal right
because my Omega is coming out of the
plane P dot is in plane so when you do
the cross product there's a sine Theta
term right and your sine Theta becomes
one because because the two vectors are
orthogonal so that's why this guy
becomes equal to two magnitude Omega
magnitude V rat and this e hat is
basically a unit Vector that determines
the direction of the Coriolis
acceleration what happened to the minus
sign factored into the direction here so
the E hat kind of takes care of the
um of the of the direction so in our
exact exaggerated case
um so you see this is the Coriolis uh
Force the acceleration is also along the
force and I'm gonna go back to the iPad
here so that's the force and it's going
to be uh perpendicular to the direction
of the motion uh of of the particle
right because again because of that
cross product effect
especially at the beginning Omega is
coming out of the plane
P dot is going to the right so your
coriolis Force at the very beginning if
I draw it with a purple Arrow
it's going to point down
a query or the acceleration is going to
be pointing down okay
um same kind of argument for the
centrifugal force I'm not going to go
into it in as much detail but again uh
you need to do the cross product twice
so you first do Omega cross B actually
why not let's do that one too
um
again on here so I can I can show you
with my hand now the directions work so
we want to do two crossbars first you do
the inner one so Omega cross P again
start here he's in that direction so
Omega cross P that's going to be a
vector pointing up right and then you do
another Omega across that one so you do
Omega
right hand rule so it's going to be
pointing to the to the left then and
then the minus sign makes it flips it
basically so the direction of the
centrifugal force is going to start
pointing outward but if you do it on the
longer uh time scales it's going to be
always kind of like radially pointing
out uh from where your point p is okay
so again if you did it on here we do
Omega Omega cross P that's going to be a
direction tangent to the circle here and
then you do another inner product with
Omega to that tangent Vector so that's
going to be radially pointing Inward and
then you flip that because of the minus
sign and your centrifugal force is going
to be pointing outwards okay so this is
just geometry basically but that's how
the two forces affect us but the
interesting one for us to design a
sensor with is this top one the Coriolis
force uh why because it's linearly
proportional at least at small time
scales right before your particle moves
too much and the trajectory deviates is
proportional directly the magnitude of a
to angular velocity and the linear
velocity of your particle in the in the
rotating reference frame right so if if
the velocity is known
um then we can calculate angular if the
linear velocity is known we can
calculate angular velocity by just
dividing the magnitude of the Coriolis
acceleration to two times the linear
velocity of the particle and now we are
on to something very very actionable
basically we just need to design some
mechanism that enables us to somehow
measure the Coriolis acceleration and
for a known linear velocity and then
basically just take the ratio of the two
times one-half and that would be our
angular velocity questions
okay so how is this done
um
just like the case of accelerometer for
gyroscopes also we need a motion
transduction mechanism and the job of
the motion transduction mechanism is to
basically transform angular velocity to
a quantifiable signal through this
Coriolis effect in the mechanical case
at least uh different Technologies are
used for motion transduction mechanical
gyroscopes uses the Coriolis effect
that's the one we'll talk about there's
Optical gyroscopes those use very
different physics it's a it's an optical
phenomena that also ties angular
velocity to something measurable but
very different physics there's also
fluid-based gyroscopes now for the case
of gyroscopes it actually turns out that
Optical gyroscopes are the most accurate
one uh that that one can design and
build but for many many robotics
applications they're not used because
Optical gyroscopes are typically pretty
large
often they're just one axis so you need
three of them mounted you know
orthogonally to get three axis gyro
sensing extremely expensive I mean the
cheapest ones you can find are probably
many tens of thousands of dollars versus
mechanical gyroscopes you can get for a
dollar so because of those reasons
Optical Gyros again in
you know everyday robotics they're not
used but for instance you see you find
Optical Gyros and atomic submarines and
you know very big
military applications and things like
that
so um
for mechanical gyroscopes there's
there's different implementations
um for for those and uh the one we will
talk about they're called uh a
vibrational or vibratory mechanical
gyroscopes and those exactly uh measure
the Coriolis acceleration that we've
been talking about and just like
accelerometers they're also fabricated
in mems process okay
so
um uh what is a vibrational or vibratory
mechanical gyroscope uh just like an
accelerometer it is a damped spring Mass
system in an enclosure but it needs two
types of motion or there's two modes as
as as we call it so one is just like the
example we saw you need to generate a
linear motion and that is actively
driven inside the device okay so that is
called the primary mode of the device or
the primary motion and then as a
rotation is applied to the device there
is going to be due to the Coriolis
effect some secondary mode excited or
generated which is the movement
perpendicular to your primary mode and
that's due to the Coriolis effect as as
we just described so you apply some
external rotation with some angular
velocity Omega again there is a primary
mode where you essentially move your
mass with some known velocity V and then
the Coriolis acceleration is going to
move your mass perpendicular to both the
axis of rotation and the primary
movement and due to the Coriolis effect
um perhaps this picture uh is much
easier to understand what is going on so
here's a mechanical diagram of a 1D
gyroscope and the way it works is that
here our axis of rotation is in and out
of the plane so that's this Omega
basically Vector coming out and this
arrow is showing the kind of like how
how it's what kind of angular motion
it's it's experiencing and then we have
this spring Mass system or a dual spring
Mass system and then in One Direction
which we call the primary mode you're
actually actively driving it by applying
some actuation Force F sub D so your
mass is kind of like constantly
oscillating back and forth in the
primary Direction and and that is
generating that the linear velocity that
we talked about that is required to
observe the Coriolis effect and then as
as soon as the device starts rotating
across uh Rel uh the the the the axis
Omega then the Coriolis effect will
generate a secondary mode or a secondary
motion perpendicular to both Omega and
your primary mode so if you do again
here the cross products so Omega is out
of the plane my primary motion is in
this direction so Omega cross V
basically right or cross P dot is going
to generate an acceleration in this
direction which is the secondary mode
so intuitively if the displacement of
the proof mass in the secondary
direction should be proportional to both
the uh the the linear velocity which we
are generating so that should be known
and the angular velocity which is what
we want to measure so in principle if we
measure displacement in the secondary
mode or in the secondary direction from
that we should be able to back out what
the angular velocity is okay I think
that's a good place to stop and then
next time we'll finish the discussion
about accelerometers